hey everyone this is kevin from the
chiefs website comm and today we're
gonna be starting a new series and i've
had a lot of people asking me to post
videos on gameplay and give commentary
on it
and so i'm going to start doing that and
the first video today i play a lot of
different chess games sometimes and just
try new stuff out and sometimes i'm
playing for real and so i'm gonna be
kind of going over some games that I've
played that I feel like go over some of
the key concepts that I've talked about
my game so hopefully as I play and kind
of talk about my game you can kind of
see okay that's kind of what he's
talking about so if you see a move I do
and you're like hey that's pretty dumb
hopefully at least you'll understand why
I did it
even if you may not have done it
everyone kind of has their own style
place so I'll kind of go over my style
play unfortunately only have ten minutes
so I'll try that cover as much as I can
so I start out afore it's kind of my
normal start out and black defends with
a Sicilian obviously as many of you know
with black defends with E 5 I like to
play the King's gambit just because it
mixes it up but he plays the Sicilian so
I just developed like normal and he
continues and I develop like normal and
I capture and he's attacking my pawn so
I'm just gonna develop my knight and he
just brings up as pawn a little bit so
I'm just gonna develop my Bishop at the
same time makes way for my King to
castle he's now attacking my knight and
I really don't like to move my knight
twice in a row
especially three times since he's
already moved so I'm just going to
develop another piece and defend that
night there
he's gonna do the same thing with his
bishop and make way for his King to
castle I'm just gonna go in castle
pretty easy move eventually I'm gonna
want my queen to move out and connect
these ropes you always want to connect
your rooks in a chess game but I feel
like I have most of my pieces developed
here so I'm feeling pretty good about my
game so far he captures which is fine
with me
I don't mind trading off Knights early
in the game I like to play wide-open
games like the I'm always one to to keep
the open middle so I like to keep my
bishops so I definitely wouldn't trade a
bishop for a knight but I would trade a
night for a night so it gets closer to
the end game which I like so we'll go
ahead and capture both down a knight and
upon their so black castles which is
logical move and we bring our rook to
the e-file which is always a good move
the King's gambit when the F files open
you can keep it on the F file because
it's a semi-open file but when you start
with E for it's always a good move to
bring your rook behind it
just kind of add protection you can
always start pushing down your
opponent's throat kind of gives you just
another piece back there to defend it so
blacks gonna start marching down making
move my bishop I'm just gonna move him
right back where it was now blacks just
going to develop his Bishop to a better
square this is kind of a prophylactic
move just kind of waiting to see what he
does I really don't want to see a bishop
here so it doesn't really hurt me I just
want to see what he does looks like he
does the same thing and I just kind of
moved my knight back here just kind of a
waiting move as well and he moves his
knight it looks like he's gonna try to
attack he's attacking my bishop and like
I said before I don't like to give up my
bishop early so I'm just gonna kind of
move him back just still kind of waiting
to see what he does I haven't really
committed to anything so far and then he
moves his Queen and he's attacking the
b2 and he's also attacking this piece
right here I really don't mind I can
kind of bait him into
taking the v2 square but definitely
wants you to fin this f2 square so I'm
gonna go ahead and move my knight
obviously I can't let him come down with
the Queen because he's protected by the
night so I've had to do something about
that now this move kind of was a turning
point in the game because from here
black kind of weakened his his King side
so I decided from here on out in my mind
I was just going to attack him on the
King side and so a lot of times you want
to know what's your plan of action is
and so at this defining moment I said
hey I'm much I'm gonna start my attack
on the Kings side so I'm gonna go ahead
and capture yes I don't have my E&B
pawns but I have good attacking prowess
that I can do so he captures I'm not
ready to trade bishops yet because I'm
on the attack so let me go ahead and
check the King he move so it's kind of
in the corner so I feel like I've got a
pretty good edge here if I can get to an
endgame I feel like I can get my King to
the middle quicker than he can there's
these small nuances that you start to
pick up on in the game so I'm gonna go
ahead and knock his Knight out of the
way he moves his knight and I'm gonna go
ahead and bring my bishop to kind of
knock his Queen out of the way and he's
attacking my bishop so I've gotta move
and I'm gonna go ahead and bring it back
to this square two defenders on this c2
square obviously he has got a bishop and
a queen here so I need to defend it and
get my bishop out of the way and he
starts to march his pawns down my throat
and I just kind of moved my knight to
the Kings side obviously I said I want
to start an attack on the Kings side
which I started to do attacking his
Bishop in the process he moves his
Bishop back obviously he's he wants to
protect that Bishop and now I move my
Queen here and this is more of a
connecting my rooks thing it's not a hey
I need to move my queen but you always
gonna you always want to connect your
rooks in a game so
that's what that was black moves his
rook kind of defending the the e-file
ethos always a good one to bring your
rook to so that's what I did I move my
pawn up just so I didn't have to
continue to worry about this this pawn
being attacked by both the Queen and the
bishop looks like he's gonna start
bringing his his pawn down so I'm gonna
go ahead and bring my my rook over a
little bit and he continues to bring his
pawn down I'm gonna go ahead and move my
bishop here I don't mind
trading off bishops now obviously I had
to get out of the way and I didn't want
to bring it to this square blocking off
my rooks so I felt like that was kind of
a wasted move so figured my best move
even though I don't want to trade off I
will because that's like this is the
best square so he decides not to he's
gonna try to block me off and I'm gonna
go ahead and bring my queen to what I
feel is a better square attacking
attacking this pawn putting some
pressure on it he starts to attack my
knight and I really don't want doubled
pawns if I take with this pawn I'll have
doubled pawns so kind of want to move
him out of the way
so we'll move him back to e2 and it
looks like black moves his king closer
to the center we're not near an endgame
but he decided that was best and I moved
this pawn up basically I'm going all all
out on the Kings side he can tapas up
but then I can take his Bishop so he
decides not to and he just moves his
Queen and I'm just gonna keep pushing my
pawn up obviously he can't take it cuz I
have a rook there and he just moves his
Bishop back and I'm gonna go ahead and
bring my bishop to a square Rock and
start to attack on the Kings side a
little bit faster and he brings his
knight here and I have no problem about
that I'm gonna go ahead and continue a
lot of people would say you know don't
leave space and your King but you know
if you feel like you have pretty good at
attacking abilities and I say go for it
you know make chest fun and if you feel
like you can win then just go out that's
kind of how I play I like to play pretty
active I'm not a reserve player so
that's why that move was there forces
him to move his knight I'm gonna go
ahead and move my knight here his queen
is kind of far away from the action so
he's gonna have to figure out something
to do so he attacks my knight here which
is fine I'm gonna go ahead and tack his
Queen make him move and he moves his
Queen back I'm gonna fork his pawn in
his rook obviously I saw later that he
just moved his rook here and defend it
but at this point I decide I really
didn't see it go anywhere so I start to
go towards the endgame I feel very
confident in the in game so I just start
to trade pieces he moves his bishop back
we trade bishops we trade Queens and now
I kind of move my rook back and now
you'll see since it's in game I try to
bring my King to the center so we both
start to bring our King to the center
and now in the past videos you hear me
talk about outpost so I have a great
outpost for my knight right here and he
can't you can't move it so as you'll see
I get defenders on this B pawn and I
keep moving my King to the center
he puts more pressure on this so I just
add another defender to it and he tries
to break up this pawn I just don't need
more about it bring this one up he
captures I capture I still have this
great outpost that Knight really doesn't
do much I'm gonna go ahead and bring my
rook into the action
we kind of go back and forth officially
moves up and I just bring my my rook to
obviously this is a huge pawn for me and
then I just trade rooks with him I have
no problem trading then I'm not moved my
knight back a little bit obviously I
have to move my rook here and now I
start pushing up the pawn and King comes
into action I take one of his and he
moves his knight and obviously this is
just in game practice I basically have
no problems trading right here and he
takes and I take and this is just kind
of a key concept he can't take this
because I can just force it down his
throat so here you'll see a lot of
people are like why would you just give
up this pawn but again I just like to
get closer to in the endgame so he's
moving
obviously I'm up in material right now
I'm up a pawn so it's just in game
tactics 101 and eventually as you will
see he takes and then I can easily win
this endgame and don't have a lot of
time so sorry for the speed up but I was
up in material and so I just kept
writing down kept writing down kept
turning down and then I had a queen and
it's a pretty easy one from here so I
hope you guys enjoy I'll try to make
more videos like this hopefully it
helped a little bit kind of going over
my thought process and how when I do
have an advantage I just go towards the
endgame and an easy win so check out
more videos in the future and subscribe
if you haven't subscribe